from trash-talking capybaras to a
space-bending casita and camilo
transforming into a giant bruno the
early versions of encounter had some
truly weird and wild storylines yipikai
movie lovers i'm jan and these are the
surprisingly strange stories disney
cancelled in encanto some spoilers ahead
of course so take care
trash talking capybaras one of my
favorite animals in encanto was chispy
the capybara whose cool unbothered
demeanor added a lovely touch of comic
relief to the drama of various scenes
and we nearly got a lot more of the cute
creatures in a very strange storyline as
early concept art for the movie reveals
some cheeky taxidermied capybaras who
like to trash talk and pass comment on
the family in fact in this piece of
concept art it looks like one of the
stuffed animals was being taken out of
the house perhaps because it was making
too much of a nuisance of itself and i
think it would have been especially
amusing to hear their take on the
disastrous proposal dinner and it looks
like this idea of talking animal heads
would have extended to even more
creatures including turtles birds and
what looks like an anteater as we see in
this unused concept art in the art of
encanto book which also has a talking
rhino and bear with a fish leave a
thumbs up and comment if you wish these
funny creatures have been in the movie
camilo in wonderland now camilo does a
fantastic evil transformation into bruno
when he describes his uncle as having a
seven foot frame during we don't talk
about bruno however encounter
co-director jared bush has revealed a
weird and wonderful animated sequence
where camilo was telling stories about
his uncle to his friends and as he
transformed he grew to an absolutely
gigantic version of him this deleted
scene has some strong alice in
wonderland vibes as a giant room with a
tiny door at the bottom looks very
similar to the room where alice meets
the talking doorknob
the indestructible pepper there's a
wacky deleted scene that disney released
of mirabelle doing chores with her
father and uncle felix abuela had tasked
them with cleaning up the house while
the rest of the magical family were sent
off to perform more spectacular tasks
this job in here is the most special
totally it totally is the scene was
meant to show the contrast between the
non-magical members of the family and
those with powers
looking great mommy watch the rock
you're welcome
still alive in this early version of the
story mirabelle's aunt peppa had the
power of indestructibility rather than
being able to control the weather this
made pipba into something of a daredevil
performing crazy deeds far too dangerous
for any ordinary person and in that
version it was mirabelle's mother
julieta who had weather powers the
problem with the indestructible pepper
though was that her powers felt too
similar to luisa's great strength so
that's why in the end she was given
control of the weather the deleted scene
also reveals a slightly different take
on why bruno or oscar as he was then
known left the family he said a bunch of
stuff well i got mad and when i will i
got mad the house got mad and he was
like i'm out and when i was like if you
leave this house you're dead to me and
oscar was like i wish i was dead then he
left the house getting mad together with
alma is from an early draft of the story
where the casita was an extension of
abuela and we would have seen this in
things like a room's wallpaper changing
to match alma's mood and colours as she
moved around the house
magical doorknob quest in a version of
the story before they'd even created the
character of mirabelle after receiving a
mysterious doorknob through the mail the
film's female protagonist was sent on a
quest to discover the secrets of the
encounter and this later concept art of
mirabel unlocking a secret door with a
magical doorknob has some intriguing
coraline and pans labyrinth vibes about
it mixed with studio ghibli an element
of the magical doorknob still made it
into the final film though when at the
end antonio gives mirabelle a doorknob
with her initial on it which she uses to
bring the reconstructed cassita back to
magical life bad casita initial concepts
for the magical house also gave it a
more mischievous personality and it was
even antagonistic towards mirabelle to
begin with bad casita initially tried to
stop mirabelle on her quest for example
there was this moment when the house
sent her shooting up into the sky
another moment where it looks like it
blocked her way through a door by
putting another door in her way and then
there was this scene where it appears to
have flooded her bedroom and in another
spooky unused scene family members
discover cassita is spying on their
private conversation about how they
think the house is crazy and in this
zany test animation mirabelle had to
compete with cassita for abuela's
approval while the house deliberately
sabotaged her efforts to please her
grandmother
funhouse casita and encanto almost had
an additional mind-bending sci-fi-ish
element blended with its magical realism
giving it shades of doctor strange or
inception where casita would have turned
itself into a fun house creating these
weird slanting disorienting corridors
and doorways that folded in on
themselves this idea also reminds me of
these trippy visuals in the third
country movie the devil made me do it
space spending casita in another
strangely entertaining version of casita
the space in the house would have made
even less logical sense for example in
this unused concept art mirabelle could
hide in this cabinet over on the left
but her arm would be able to emerge
magically through this cupboard on the
right so she could sneak a pastry or two
with a bell's deep dive and in another
unused casita storyline there was a vast
underwater world beneath the house that
mirabelle had to explore which i suspect
was part of her original quest
magical wallpaper in the end the
filmmakers opted to make casita a much
friendlier character and we can see that
change in this unused concept art where
the house helped mirabelle by folding
pieces of wallpaper into magical birds
that would guide her on a mission to
discover the mystery of the encanto in
some other art it also appears the
wallpaper could act as a portal or door
to a magical world behind the walls in
this art a door seems to open up an
isabella's bedroom wall to a place where
she could relax and be happy then
there's this unused art which shows how
originally cassita's mood was going to
reflect mirabelle's mood for example
here you can see the wallpaper crying
while mirabella feels sad at being left
out of the family fun and the house also
joined in on reenactments of historical
battles with isabella's magical potato
people more on that later
coffee with cassita i love this idea of
mirabelle sharing a morning coffee with
the magical house and putting hats on
the chairs and lamp the casita
communicated through we got a little
touch of this rejected idea in the final
movie when cassita pours coffee for the
family
luisa holds up the sky it's a shame we
didn't get to see inside luisa's room
because there were some very cool ideas
for how it would look for instance the
room would have had several large
boulders that fell from above and luisa
had to keep them up with her feet that
idea was intended to be reminiscent of
the myth of atlas carrying the sky most
of the things in the room appear to be
made of rocks including the stone bed
but one especially sweet contrasting
detail is the little puppy louisa holds
and there's some more cute concept art
of luisa with puppies here
jungle furniture as impressive as
antonio's room is in the movie an early
idea had an even more surreal design for
example the furniture inside had merged
with parts of the rainforest and the
windows were portals into the jungle
with waterfalls streaming through in the
end though these were deemed too
confusing to use for the final film
colombian rock as for the emerald vision
tablet that mirabelle found in bruno's
room the original design was a lot more
stylized and its look was inspired by
the san agustin statues in colombia
alma's nightmare abuela's trauma from
losing her husband pedro was a key
element of the final movie but in an
earlier storyline she was also going to
have a nightmarish vision of some
terrifying ghost-like horse riders which
would have brought back the horrors of
what happened by the river with pedro
the idea was scrapped though for being
too scary and also because it was
considered too similar to scenes with
the droon in disney's raya and the last
dragon
the forbidden forest another dark
deleted storyline had mirabelle
venturing outside the safety of casita
and into what was dubbed a forbidden
forest the off-limits spiky wooded area
looks like it's part of an early version
of the movie where mirabelle was going
to discover isabella's secret garden in
fact isabella was incredibly different
in the original encounter story she had
a secret boyfriend who she married and
she could even create living magical
potato creatures and you can get all the
details on that in my isabella deleted
scenes video tap here to watch it and
there's also a link in the video
description plus subscribe and hit the
bell so you don't miss my next disney
video so movie lovers would you like to
see any of these unused story lines in
an encounter sequel let me know what you
think in the comments below tap left for
my full encounter playlist and discover
the shocking alternate endings to the
movie you never got to see and if you
liked this do leave a thumbs up i really
appreciate it thanks for enjoying this
movie with me and hope you have a
marvelous movie loving week yippie kai
movie lovers
you